frustración y mucho cansancio son los
sentimientos de los migrantes retenidos
en Ciudad Juárez localidad fronteriza
entre México y Estados Unidos yo perdí
la selva y todo donde todo lado porque
supuestamente El emigrante no le pueden
dar cola al emigrante no lo pueden
ayudar en ningún lado si emigrar no es
un delito allí muchos pasaron a la noche
en refugios antes de intentar cruzar a
Estados Unidos y acusaron a malos tratos
por parte de las autoridades mexicanas y
falta de protección en general
no queremos estar en su país lo que
procuramos es es este que tengan vaya
que tengan lugar seguro que tengan un
este
un espacio donde donde puedan estar a
salvo todo apenas dos días después de
que cientos de migrantes intentaran
cruzar en la frontera masivamente tras
rumores de que se permitiría su entrada
a suelo estadounidense Pero la realidad
que encontraron fue muy diferente a la
esperada agentes con escudos abarricadas
Y alambre de Espino
por favor queremos respuestas la
aplicación no nos ha servido para
absolutamente nada la aplicación ya no
da nada viejo
me encuentro
Y es que muchos como Camila Cruz llevan
hasta seis meses esperando una cita para
solicitar asilo en Estados Unidos
acusando que el proceso de asilo que el
presidente Joe biden lanzó en enero
pensado para garantizar la seguridad de
los migrantes tiene carencias la pobreza
y la violencia en sus países de origen
lleva a que unas 200.000 personas
intenten cruzar la frontera hacia
Estados Unidos cada mes